it's not going to turn on until there's
enough hydrogen pressure so we'll see
what happens are we generating some of
my good friends on the rowing team we're
like oh you've got to take this class
it's great for but you're the kind of
person who loves to build things and
you're in the right place we're working
on projects that have been tried and
failed they bring us these very
interesting real-world issues is it what
we're trying to do is harness the
electricity that's inherent in an
aluminum as an element by reacting it
with water may I see you like big air
bubbles going oh the idea is to build
something that works so it's run as
close to a realistic startup as possible
which means that you need to use every
resource you can get your hands on we've
had one company spin out of this class
we have access to bandsaw to a mill too
late all of these things you need to
rapid prototype you may be on your scale
it up with a regulator this class
teaches you to collaborate effectively
really important and you learn a lot
when you're doing something that no one
has ever done before we're gonna run
into things that no one understands yet
that's what makes it such an engaging
experience is because there is no
specific right answer it's the circuit
for the salt water it's the needy likes
Eric system they do intend to start
testing it as a cover the Russians in
the united states have both been looking
at aluminum as a fuel for underwater
vehicles for 25 years and have not
succeeded our class has succeeded